no you're awesome something can I tell
you I'm gonna tell you something that
happened to me the other day that I I
wasn't going to talk about but no let's
do it
but it's a little thing that happened
and I haven't told anybody except for
kalila oh snap secrets so I i worked on
NCIS los angeles again last week awesome
thank you and i play a CIA agent yes I
just I got they say I can do it okay
CIA agent so the last day I was there I
was driving to because we had to drive
into the [ __ ] mountains and it's like
an hour and a half away because they had
to create the Vietnam jungle and some
[ __ ] reservoir camping site so I just
decided to stop by bagel brothers and it
was a Asian guy there I go hey yeah
they had one last jalapeno bagel gang
you down so hungry but he put on like 16
layers of cream cheese in the middle
he's lactose intolerant oh so you know
how the the the bay goes hot yeah it was
stick to it being you know made the
basic yeah I wasn't eating it like an
animal because I was like late you know
and so I go to my dressing room and
there's army fatigues but there's also
next to a wetsuit oh no and it says a
note put the wet suit underneath the
karmatit fatigue don't worry no one's
gonna ever see the wet suit gonna
[ __ ] wear a wet suit underneath this
[ __ ] army fatigue okay know what -
[ __ ] the waiter Fung doing right yeah
[ __ ] the what sue okay okay so and then
I put the guns in and had a machine gun
yeah yeah and then as I'm walking to the
set which is like a half a mile away
into the [ __ ] woods I hear my stomach
oh like that bubble guts bagel yeah but
I'm like I'm fine
so now it's me LL Cool J Chris O'Donnell
Eric Danni of the whole cast and we're
in the jungle and and all of a sudden
you know you're walking out of the
jungle with your machine gun and then
they go action and the rain hit my body
it was a rain scene
the rain was so [ __ ] cold I went
right into hypothermic shock it's just
literally just started shaking like III
also in my head I'm like there's no way
I can do this I cannot do it gives lines
during all this no okay right good so
I'm shaking like this and then you know
I mean the ad whether they come up think
you're all right they're like well
you're wearing a wetsuit
right and everyone even Ella coogee they
all turn around go what are you a
[ __ ] idiot
it was in your dressing room right yeah
I didn't think there was gonna be
raining as I'm talking right I hear this
oh no and a little fart came out was it
a shart or a fart strictly sharp no fart
I mean so you go alright go but go again
go back to your marks
mm-hmm action no I hope they don't use
it because no unlike you know so scared
it's my body right yeah I start turning
blue in fact the point where Jam dad you
know the dad from Dexter yeah huh he's
in a - and he comes up to me goes hey
man you can't do this you're gonna go
into hypothermic shock cuz even him he's
an old man because I'm [ __ ] going
into it and I have two layers of wet
suit on yeah and I go I have to take a
[ __ ] because hey cut he goes he needs to
take go to the bathroom he said before
and they're like we're losing light oh
my god I'm shaking and like a farting
it was the worst human experience of my
life
action again rocky use the bathroom he
now gets to the point where I'm like
alright if you don't let me guys go to
the bathroom I'm gonna [ __ ] right here
and there right here people laugh no
because now they I told him it's a [ __ ]
bathroom is one thing me pee yes [ __ ] I
had to take diarrhea now yeah right and
we're losing light can you hold it they
said no I go well I'm leaving I ran
through the forest
and with this American Indian guy who
was my border by saying he's a follow me
this way and I normally wouldn't but
he's American Indian he knows [ __ ] do
you know the woods he does yeah he knows
that she knows the way you know so I
trusted them right
sheesh if we shift over running you mean
another trail I got go ahead jerky your
reward
yeah go ahead sure yeah my Cherokee
friend right you know what half a mile
we finally see this white leg built like
a little building like a and that's what
the bathroom is you could just go up the
stairs and go to the bathroom right as I
hit a stair I hear this pop pop like
that [ __ ] just hop out of my butthole
pop hard like hard hard and now it's
over now of a failure because now I have
to [ __ ] wipe the [ __ ] off my you know
it's a whole thing and also now they're
waiting for me I know you hate that
feeling right so I look at my underwear
and there's tube chunks of [ __ ]
I take toilet paper wiping it's all go
away what you know just throw the
underwear away yeah it's my only layer
of my dick would freeze off he would
have hypothermia
I'd have hypothermia did I like how his
underwear are you like protected yeah
that's awesome so that as I'm and then I
[ __ ] and it was like dude luckily the
first two pop-ups were were a little
dryer and yeah because the second act it
was like a standing ovation it was like
it was like
Shh you know man like into the [ __ ]
it would have been a disaster so then I
do it quickly i clinched the [ __ ]
involved with my cheating with my strong
ass cheeks the muscle the muscle yeah I
put my clothes back on
I still have [ __ ] all over my ass ass
part the cheeks right why didn't you
wipe that he's a nice dog friends oh
yeah yeah just generally doesn't do it I
don't do we smell your chair right now
it's just baby
he has crust in his hamstrings yeah well
that's a road now walk back right
which-which [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] ass
cheeks and the clothing is just wet into
my body and I'm shaking and I go back on
the set and now I guess somebody I told
somebody that I [ __ ] my pants now
everyone's laughing but you don't care
do you care well no because it think I'd
rather have them laugh and be angry oh
right so I you know I finish it and I'm
like it's over I mean this is a disaster
but nothing happened
oh nice but still that whole experience
it was a nightmare it was the biggest
nightmare I've ever had on a set really
to [ __ ] your pants
oh no your guest starring on a show you
know and then but then a showrunner came
up to me and he was like a really nice
Wow yeah I don't know that's our
memories are made man yeah what's the
last time you [ __ ] your pants I [ __ ] my
pants the last time oh man I don't know
maybe like 10 years ago
yeah I was an adult then yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah I'm not I'm I'm
gonna try to hide that it was it was
horrible I was running late for work as
before we did the whole YouTube thing or
anyway I had a really nice business suit
on was your job before I was a baker was
really boring yes I had a really nice
suit on and I was running late I'm like
I can I can make it like I have
that [ __ ] like nothing's gonna happen
minds to very type well that's what I
thought
oh until they got tested and then it was
just like a little bit and then it just
all came out oh my god man suit yeah
like I had a drive like my butt was not
oh yeah how did you strive back home
that's it oh you don't commit you're not
you're not Asians would have gone to
work yeah the crusty hands yeah very
definitely much I'm definitely Beck's
penis
[Music]